Thanks okay Wendy I told the agency to
send anybody over regardless of
experience because we're desperate for
help this summer I just have another kid
quit on me today it's nice to have an
adult applying for a change
Thanks I'm changing careers and it's
difficult to get into a new field Oh
what was your last job it was kind of a
whore
are we all on the way huh I guess so
okay Wendy let's see exactly how you
sold your sucker
okay says here you were a dancer were
these national tours no there were strip
clubs I put down dancing because I
thought it sounded better mm-hmm I see
okay let's forget about job experience I
don't think any of its gonna apply okay
special skills eating while driving
explain that you know how it's good to
kill two birds or two stones what can i
smoke in here no anyway if I'm hungry
and I got to do a lot of errands I get
my car I go through the drive-thru and I
eat while I do my errands you know like
if I got to pick up a girl it doesn't
have a car or I gotta score some super
cool or I gotta buy a box of condoms and
balls okay Wendy special skills don't
apply either uh you have a section on
your resume entitled my do's and don'ts
I've never seen that before
thank you you're welcome okay what does
this mean I won't ask the Dean you can't
see on my f1 suck you you can't on my
face I put it in initials cuz I thought
it sounded better I wouldn't put that on
my resume well that's my old resume
what does DP stand for double
penetration TP triple penetration fa / P
/ LM farm animals pets lunch weeks well
inside of C I won't lay inside a coffin
f of t I won't fist a turkey DHD of a HC
I will not suck a double-headed dildo on
a hovercraft that's insane I know that's
why I won't do it uh Secret Santas that
way hope it is yeah yeah every Christmas
we do Secret Santa and I always give the
best gifts oh great
like one year I gave this chick the hand
of Adonis
minty grab bag Oh what was that
it's a 12-inch dildo with balls okay
Wendy
I'm sorry I'd love to give you your
first break but you're just not
qualified for this job oh you are huh
you know I wouldn't act so superior if I
were you what are you like 40 plus years
old yeah settled from managing a bunch
of teenagers in a franchise coffee shop
it's not what you dreamed of you're
young and beautiful
no oh Christ I wanted to be an astronaut
Hey it's never too late to be what we
want to be
[Music]
she needs
[Applause]
[Music]
you've given me the strength to follow
my dreams I'm gonna quit this place and
join the space program good for you and
I'm gonna throw you a wild party cuz
I've never had an astronaut friend
before
you